nice my stepmoms friend with their super
into horses out there in Colorado and
this is years ago bitter titty better to
have them dole dole team but dull flat
dole grat hello flat cake just smell
like [ __ ] bitter teeth at the front
tooth by bitter titty up now this was I
was a kid when it happened I want to say
she lost the titty Christ they can put
implants in but I'm pretty sure she lost
cities get that thing off like an old
grape on a vine stop it what you do next
time is you get that bird reaching for
the sky you get them up you get them up
and out of the nest you if it's a small
bird get him get him reaches you oil up
you oil a shot you get creative
hold on I'm gonna tell you and then you
get that camera under the balls you get
that camera under the balls no you work
in angles now you get a friend of yours
who's got tiny hands you get those hands
and that you act like it's your hands
because Brett's got some big hands and
then you get your friend have those
hands kind of hover over over the head
of that big old that well you want some
you want some kid hands you got one so
you get a doll then you don't get a dog
get a dog okay I was gonna say Kay's a
real kick cuz you can get good at you up
for moving Chris mood a cues me sir yeah
are you doing no Chris Hansen comes out
you don't want that pointers get a doll
with those tiny little hands you just
kind of like it's like hold initially
good got this the prom she's like oh my
god that's a big old piece sir and
you're in the hall of fame I'm game then
you come on over and she goes what the
[ __ ] man trick photography
ya gotta fee you seen avatar [ __ ] seen
avatar it's your senior a spark okay
steer X's are real LA and I was 3d it's
fun that's all it's still fly use my
still open the more you zoom lens and
you fell for it but I got you here while
you're here while you're here I'm sorry
you need for dinner there you snapchat
before it's a filter yeah I I don't
realize look that big paid for dinner
don't be such a size Queen
yeah don't be don't be a hater on small
dick plus I got small dick I got strong
hips small penises matter lady and then
she ran at him I think she blasted that
dick pic out horrible how mean I know
there I have taken pictures of the piece
ten-hut and my hand will be on it and I
go I don't like the contrast I'm gonna
take the hand away old weathered
more than I wanted to look I want yeah
but let's be honest is it's also like
like your hands like this old kind of
like old old like cramp a hand mr. Daaga
I ran grandpa hand yeah you know like a
weathered hand I've got some arthritis
in the joint and yeah I'm not cold I
can't put my hands in me I got like
scars on and stuff she's like goddamn my
my hands look like [ __ ] I don't know you
know what I do sometimes when I take a
dick pic I'll get a black man's hand on
it I'll get a black man never matter you
taught my chocolate here I'll have a
friend of mine I'll never have a black
friend of mine grab and grab my own go
grab my white dick and that's a nice
contrast I'm not I never met the the old
cocoa Christian hand attack I'm like
listen up bro you're straight I'm
straight you're a black man I'm a white
man grab a handful I'm gonna give you
I'm gonna put 50 bucks in your pot and
just like it
yep cuz I know just on principle so you
don't feel like you're doing it for free
cuz a man a man wants to feel like he's
straight-up fistful don't don't squeeze
too hard right now if you squeeze
actually do squeeze too hard want you to
herniate the head want to be a little
bit purple yeah yeah bigger yeah I like
that thing to get a pop and say yeah pop
that out go ahead and get that chocolate
hand in here
I caught the old the old chocolate he
called the chocolate hand trick mmm
chocolate filter chocolate Hannah fax a
new uh it's a new snapchat I like it
that would be a good thing like if
Instagram was not even Instagram if
snapchat was doing Aspen that's a good
business there you go you got it let's
be honest guys send dick pics so let's
say you come up with an app that maybe
mix it up with the dick so it's not so
creepy maybe it has a bow tie on it
maybe it's like it comes with a dick in
a box so it looks like it yeah and maybe
you click it and boom weather is maybe
it looks like the Loch Ness monster
peeking out of the water you have all
these fun filters god it's called dick
filter I was lifting heavy weight heavy
yeah we're talking about wood this is
squad this was this was big brown but
like real you're doing football weight
will football weight I get some love
handles I'm sweating all the time I got
a weird weird fro going I'm eating
whatever I want everyone deadlift in the
kazoo all I care abouts getting swole my
[ __ ] gone out I could wiper
not a good wiper but I'm driving and I
get the most intense itch in my [ __ ]
like I'm like hey I was driving
yeah [ __ ] son yeah you need a new you
need an Oscars now you need an ostrich
yeah
I need a [ __ ] velociraptor call in
that [ __ ] you can't I swear to God I
almost crashed my car at the time at a
Cadillac CTS I'm [ __ ] driving like oh
my god oh my god
I mean I go I don't I don't go finger to
[ __ ] I went through the underwear
that small field here that small filter
you're still gonna your hands through
gonna smell like [ __ ] let's be we all
been there of course and I still reached
in there and I scratched that thing like
it would like my life depend on yeah god
damn it feels good well guess what that
it went huh oh no I imagine so when turn
the flame on because now it didn't go
from really itchy
it's getting each year that's gonna burn
Jesus and then I was like hold up is
there is there a snake coming out my
[ __ ]
you know Brendan that would be a
hemorrhoid sir no I could get in the
mirror you know get embarrassing yes
yeah I had to bend over like a bad porno
hook between my legs it looked like
there's a great coming out of my [ __ ]
oh great like a great really your purple
grape purple grape yeah and once you sew
it out that is that a vein what is
that's a vein that protrudes through the
anus oh Christ
so what like like tremors it looked like
the movie tremors coming on my [ __ ]
so I had to take the old the old one-two
digit and just go ahead and nut up in
here push them back in ready push him
back go ahead and push them back in well
they don't like that no science right
there bro that's bro sign I wait you
know what you're poking out I'm gonna
push you in he went oh I'm going in but
guess what this time I'm coming with
friends now three of them came out he
went we're gonna go away
oh no we coming back with friends ah
those three okay guys
hey guys some resistance I need some
backup hey I need backup portal oh come
on oh ho really turn to stick around
push me somebody get my hips and push me
through yeah Oh three of them there's
the three-headed months know now that
itching you never you never felt pain
brother you have to go to the hospital
sometimes yeah I thought I was gonna
have to put out super-embarrassed
so I did some research now we do bro
research what about bro science can I
can I say can I can i gasps Gary
rabbit-hole can I guess put some
on that bad boy no there's like pepper
H&H use white peas don't lift real hard
try not to [ __ ] so much
don't don't sit on the toilet for longer
than you have to drink lots of water one
time I was talking on this girl this
girl I never forget this on vacation
again in Greece and there's this
beautiful girl who's swimming laps
she's French I hear her speaking French
daddy speaks a little French here's you
know little closer self daddy call
myself daddy I I wait till she's kind of
taking a little she's taking a little
rest and yeah go ahead keep going be and
she's taking a little rest and I got a
look at her I'm talking to her in French
no to Tunisia Libya not Halloween I see
and I hear look up and my sister goes
kind of mom and just [ __ ] cannonballs
in between us real talk splashes her
shirt is the dis disaster cock-block
supreme my sister maids will call her
cock-block supreme I couldn't wait to
ruin every chance though sure are soo
sure are oh yeah I love her I told I
told you my brother was dating this girl
I won't say her name if so I'll put it
this way for a while J only liked dark
meat if he only dated black women right
no it's not true all right but he'll if
you went to KFC prefer dark meat and
white meat he didn't deceive opportunity
employers what you're saying yeah so on
high maybe high school I mean he might
have been in middle school I forgive his
dance girl she was so mean to me man and
but she wore lip gloss all the time
I went ahead and empty out half that lip
gloss when put a little my peepee in
there so when J and her would make it
out he was tasting that piss house my
husband pissed and I yelled from the top
of stairs like new he's gonna beat the
[ __ ] on me and how's that pp taste and
boy did he get and I ran out the door
Miranda I couldn't [ __ ] stand that
girl she was so mean to me that's the
only thing I thought he'd beat your ass
oh he beat me up so much yeah all the
time
yeah all the time big it's big boys
there's a very rude there's a real
ritual with people who own elephants the
MA
in India and in Thailand they clean them
they bathe them they brush them but
they're always know they always know yes
that they could that's when people die
when that when they're like the
zookeeper something like that when they
get a little too loosey-goosey on the
animals they forget that their handles
and do some wild [ __ ] it's gonna give
them a me [ __ ] inch correct
yeah dad do me a favor when you have a
tiger don't fall around it don't fall
yeah yeah hey that's why I never when I
bring my up my Tiger is out I never do
it on ice it's very strange that people
want to own that [ __ ] that's never
crossed my mind I've owned a bunch of
animals like you name it normal animals
I've had normal but I've never been like
god I'd love a tiger it's the feeling of
danger like I'm the only one that can be
around this tiger or do you have a tiny
dick tomorrow night we're celebrating
your wife's birthday don't we that's
right buddy I was told now I was told no
boo at Malibu and then you went I'll
just play making dinner at the house
yeah having a chef come over she'll be
39 and the bummer about that is that
when she's 40 I have to leave your
trailer in well looks like a lease well
yeah I can't I mean 40 you know you
don't want the old model discussed yeah
I know you want that new mom honey
listen I love you thanks for the
memories but your 40 discuss it weird
guys can do that girls can